In 1999, the German newspaper Dezite ran an experiment.
They asked a falafel salesman and former theater director,
Salah Ben Galli, who in the world he would most like
to be connected to.
He chose his favorite actor, Marlon Brando.
So the reporters then searched for a chain of friends,
family, or acquaintances, people who knew each other
on a first-name basis, who could connect Ben Galli to Brando.
As it happens, Ben Galli had a friend in California.
This friend worked alongside the boyfriend of a woman
who was the sorority sister of the daughter of the producer
of the film Don Juan de Marco, starring Marlon Brando.
So in total, it took just six steps,
six degrees of separation.
And the idea is that this is not a unique example,
that you could connect any two people on the planet
in six steps or less.
But is it really true?
And if it is, how does it affect our lives?
How is this possible in a world of now eight billion people
that we could be that close, just six hops or less?
Does that affect how diseases spread,
how information travels?
Our math showed the question is not why is the world small?
It's really how could it be otherwise?
But then I got a call from the FBI.
We are making the world smaller all the time.
I could suppose to be good.
And yet it does expose you to toxicity and malevolence
that you might have been shielded from.
You look at the net effect of it.
And it's actually been pretty negative by a lot of...